my name is Dan Miller I work for Unity
Technologies as an X R evangelist so I
mostly focus on AR and VR but I've done
a lot of mobile game development in the
past and built a lot of Android
applications and what I want to do today
is talk a little bit about some best
practices for unity development inside
the Android ecosystem so there's gonna
be some fairly kind of basic or easy
wins as well as talking about things you
can do and how to kind of understand and
start some of the debugging process as
well as some newer features and things
that are maybe still a little bit in
early access and if you are kind of
publishing your game in the near coming
months you'll see some of these things
starting to come out and just some
strategies that you can take advantage
of as a developer so before I get
started I want to ask how many people
have heard of unity or are aware of the
unity editor or engine all right lots of
hands there so if you're not aware unity
is a piece of software or a tool for
writing interactive applications and
we've done a lot of work to make it very
easy to develop and create your games
and publish them to stores like the
Google Play Store there's actually
integrated settings in the publish
settings so you can set up a lot of your
things build out your apk and push it up
right away all right
and so what I want to do first is just
go through what I call some easy wins
some basic kind of techniques to
consider when publishing and developing
your application within the unity editor
next I'm going to talk about ADB the
Android debug bridge how you can set
that up and how you can utilize that to
get some information about what's
actually happening with your application
running on Android back to your PC and
after that I'm just going to talk a
little bit about kind of reducing the
apk size on your application so that you
can make it easier for users to get a
hold of your app try it right away and
not have to wait for a long download
time or downloading it over something
like Wi-Fi all right so let's start with
some easy wins the first thing I want to
talk about is just texture Atlas II and
what this is is it's really common in 2d
development where you
all of your sprites together in a single
texture what this allows you to do is
reduce draw calls and you can then kind
of split it up to use different little
sprite sheets for each individual sprite
but have them all kind of packed here on
a certain texture and while this works
really well for 2d it's also pretty
common to do it for 3d as well you can
see there's two little bug creatures
here one's more of a dragonfly and one's
a ladybug but they're actually using the
same texture here and just referencing
different parts of it so when you're
creating things like 3d assets you can
consider laying out the UVs on a shared
UV sheet here and then reference the
same texture to again just reduce draw
calls and kind of optimize your
application now the other thing to
consider is kind of how you're
compressing your textures and what sort
of shaders you're using to render your
3d models and again this is more on the
3d side but does apply a little bit to
2d so one thing to keep in mind is right
now inside the unity editor the standard
shader is PBR or physically based
rendering and this is meant to kind of
reflect the lighting conditions and
features in the real world we have
reflective surfaces that are able to
kind of reflect the environment around
them similar to what we have that exists
in the real world things like different
lighting settings and stuff like that
now depending on what sort of
application you're making or what sort
of stylistic choice you're making with
your models it's not always really
appropriate to have these PBR materials
and have all these different options for
what you need you can see here that
these two bugs are a little bit more
stylized or cartoon-like so it doesn't
necessarily make sense to have them
fully kind of going through the
processes that's required to render them
based on physically-based properties so
what I've done here is I'm actually have
two different materials that are backed
one by the standard shader and one by a
much lighter shader here and you can see
the kind of settings here and even
without fully understanding what's
happening at the shader level you can
easily
the contrast between the differences of
the kind of instructions or the maps
that are associated with this and you'll
see here on one side we have just a
simple texture assignment and on the
other while we have that texture
assignment we also have all these
different settings what I haven't
actually adjusted them all at all and if
I go back there you can kind of almost
barely see a difference between how the
lighting and the rendering is set up
here so something to really keep in mind
depending if you're using 3d models and
the actual stylistic approach that you
want to your assets is just considering
using a more light lightweight shader or
a mobile-optimized shader so within
unity and the material settings you can
actually drop-down choose the shader
that's backed for that material and
there is a specific mobile one as well
so really kind of consider this when
setting up your 3d models and the last
thing and this is something that's kind
of unique to the Android platform is
within the unity editor in the
application namespace and API we
actually have an is genuine check and
what you can do here is in your code you
can go and check if the apk is genuine
and what it means to be genuine is if it
is directly downloaded from the Google
Play Store and has not been altered now
we all know that apks can be fairly
easily distributed and this is really
helpful for testing or you know letting
your buddy try out your game before it's
released and what you can do in your app
is that you can use this is genuine
check to potentially restrict some
features or things like that so you
could restrict access to the in-app
store that's in your thing you could
also restrict access to maybe certain
levels or something if the if the is
genuine check is not passed now
something to keep in mind is that this
is a fairly expensive call so if you are
using it consider using it at a single
point before you kind of show different
features or applications and don't try
to call this every frame as that will
get pretty expensive
all right and now I just want to dive a
little bit into debugging and this is
kind of a process that I go through when
developing any apps on Android it is a
little bit more rudimentary
but kind of helps you get a base start
to start to understand what's going on
and how to integrate this and so for
this I use ADB so ADB is the Android
debug bridge and what it is is it's
basically a robust command-line tool
that allows you to link in directly to
your Android device you can do this
through USB by just plugging into your
device opening up the adb console and
then there's a lot of associated
commands as well as flags that you can
use to get information back now one
thing to keep in mind is that ADB gives
you a lot of information back and if
you're not using any filtering it'll be
hard to even really read or understand
what's happening as information just
continually flies through in the console
itself so what can you do for this well
you can actually set a specific unity
flag but again I just wanted to kind of
highlight here that as a developer when
you're connecting your device via ADB or
REO via your computer you can do it via
USB and if you're using a more modern
phone one thing to keep in mind is that
you will need to unlock and look at your
phone and actually allow those USB
debugging and that's an option in the
developer settings so if you guys are
developing for Android hopefully your
Android device is already in developer
mode and there's a little checkbox there
for allowing USB debugging and then from
here you can connect it to your computer
and then start hooking up ADB and
getting some information back it is also
available via Wi-Fi and you can do this
via the connected editor within in the
console window within unity so as I
mentioned there's actually a flag or a
callback here
and you can do a dash S unity and
that'll give you specific callbacks from
your app running in unity so here I just
have a small little debug log then every
time I change the orientation from
portrait to landscape landscape it just
outputs ad
message within my console in the app and
as I'm running this on my phone and as
it's connected you can actually see
these callbacks through ADB now it'll
also output things like air Zorn all
reference exceptions which if you
developed a lot of applications in unity
you know you always get those a lot
where certain things aren't hooked up or
certain things aren't initialized before
your trying to call them and you can get
that information back via ADB so you can
start kind of tracing and understanding
where those issues are coming from
alright and now what I want to do is
talk a little bit about reducing the
size of your apk so within unity and
just really when building any sort of
application especially in the mobile
ecosystem you know that how fast your
user can actually play and experience
your game is crucial in getting them to
be retained and continue to play it and
so part of this is kind of a strategy
for delivering a small apk or a small
application that they can get started
with right away they can download not
over Wi-Fi and they can really just
start experiencing so for this there's a
couple different strategies both built
into unity and the Google Play Store and
I want to talk about how you as a
developer can start taking advantage of
those alright so the first one is
splitting the apk by target architecture
now this is a little bit of a newer
function so it's available in the latest
version of unity in 2018 point two so
that's the latest stable release
available now and what it allows you to
do is it allows you to check which apk
target architectures you specifically
want when you build out your app now the
Play Store actually allows you to upload
different versions of the apk for all
these target architectures and then
depending on what device you're on in
what target architecture it has it'll
actually download these separate apks
previously inside unity when you had
packaged up in apk you would target
certain architectures and it would all
kind of be combined into a single apk
which ended up below
sighs a little bit so this is just an
easy kind of win where you can separate
things out and it'll output different
apks depending on which checkboxes you
hit this is also a step towards
compliance with things like the new
Android P as well as just some
requirements as you start to build out
your apps the other thing that supported
is something called apk expansion files
or oh oh bebe and what this is is this
is a way to build a kind of base unit of
your game think of something like the
main menu and the first couple levels
and then actually split it up into what
we call expansion files which are
downloaded alongside your game and again
this is a way for your users to download
your application right away and then
start feeding in the necessary data to
then experience later levels if someone
downloads your app right now they might
be ok they might just want to play the
first couple levels and not have to wait
for the entire thing to download or the
entire size of your apk so how do you
take advantage of this within unity well
there's a small checkbox there to build
out these OBB files within the publish
settings under player settings once you
build this out it'll actually again kind
of separate your apk and through the
Google Play Store you can upload these
alongside of it now because Android is a
more of an open ecosystem you do have to
be careful about users deleting these oh
OBB files and you can't really restrict
them from cleaning up their phone
deleting some things to try to clear up
maybe space for another app or something
like that so it is required that if you
do this you actually provide a way for
the user to redownload these files
within your app so how do you do this
well Google provides some documentation
on how to actually integrate it on their
side of things for native applications
and on the unity side if you guys just
all want to take a picture of this exact
function and call back
and I was just kidding on that there's
actually a asset store package here that
we've written that allows you to easily
go and kind of integrate that extra
download that's required if you do split
up your application using these OBB
files so again this is kind of a setting
built into unity to split up your app in
order to have kind of the main part of
the game something like the main menu in
the first couple levels and then
expansion files that complete the rest
of your application and the real goal
here is to try to get under that a
hundred megabyte limit so that your
users are not required to download your
app via Wi-Fi and so this you can see is
just the Google Play OBB and it's free
on the unity asset store which just has
this little code snippet here as well as
some sample scenes and examples that
allows you to then put a button into
your app which is a requirement for the
Play Store when using that alright and
now I want to talk a bit about Google
Play instant so this was mentioned in a
lot of previous talks and it's something
that I think is really exciting and kind
of what's possible in coming in the
future
so Google Play Instant is a way for
users to try out your game even quicker
it's a smaller bite-sized experience
that may be something like a single
level or really a taste of what your
full application and game can be and how
do you start to integrate this or how do
you build this within unity well
Google's actually made a plug-in it's
still in beta but the cool thing you can
see here is that it's very actively
being worked on I think this release
says here that it was released something
like four days ago that was actually
four days ago so eight days ago this
plug-in was updated and released and
it's really kind of being actively
developed and it is kind of a special
part of the store right now where you
can give your users access to it now to
integrate this and use this within unity
there's a lot of additional kind of
steps and set
so that you need to go through fairly
carefully but Google has done a really
good job of providing a menu here and it
actually walks you through the required
steps you drop down the Google Play
instant you can actually build to the
instant architecture and then run that
on your device and it gives you this
small little sample of your app and
packages it all up for you so this is
directly integrated into unity so you
can start taking advantage of it now and
build these instant Play apps and that's
pretty much it for my talked so thanks a
lot